in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Nick
and Whitney are with us hey guys are you
hey welcome and you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes sir now where do
you guys live I'm guessing st. Louis
with the st. Louis Blues jerseys on we
don't live too far from San Luis we live
in a little town called Leopold Missouri
now where is Leopold closer to Southeast
Missouri it's about a town of a hundred
people okay all right very cool well
welcome to Nashville thank you so you're
gonna go the predator Predators game
tonight I guess we're gonna go to the
Blues game I think they're playing the
Predators I think they're playing at the
predator that's there we'll see we'll
see who plays at the end the game okay
it's good we're in dadgum side enemy
colors and my building here I mean G
yeah so anyway you're here to do your
dead free stream how much have you paid
off we've paid off one hundred and
eighteen thousand dollars all right how
long did that take you four years and 11
months four years and 11 months four
years and 11 months making what kind of
money per year during that time we
started at 60,000 and now we're up to
about ninety ninety two thousand
excellent what do you two do for a
living I am a schoolteacher and I'm a
nurse excellent very good night very
good so what kind of debt was a hundred
and eighteen thousand dollars a lot of
Blues tickets put on hockey tickets
right there I never had that one before
okay it was a mixture of everything we
had credit card debt we had a lot of
student loan debt at a couple of medical
bills it was just everything we had it
all Whitney was the Thomas thing y'all
overbought on debt fast food quick
answer just like that very cool so what
was the biggest part that student loans
yes student loans were the biggest one
in the last one we paid off yeah okay
getting Sallie Mae booted out of the
house as a joyous experience we give her
her eviction papers we we pushed that we
left on yesterday and we pushed the
final payment bummin button the day we
left I love that so that's fun very cool
and come to Nashville to the hockey game
to celebrate that's gross and stop by
and doing that free scream that's right
now their priorities straight here four
years of 11 months is a long haul it is
but now that we look back at it it
wasn't that bad one thing that we had to
remember was you know this was a
marathon not necessarily a sprint we ran
hard and we ran fast but we also looked
at the big picture and that's what made
it made it worthwhile because when we
first started we weren't making a lot of
money compared to the debt we had so we
just had to hang tough and luckily she
worked with me and I worked with her and
we did it so what happened four years
and eleven months ago that puts you on
this path it was it was deer season and
I was bow hunting with my cousin and we
came in for a afternoon nap and a meal
and we laid down and I saw this book
with this bald guy on it and I said well
I think I'll read this book while it's
just a to rest for a little bit and it
was your total money money bug gonna put
you to sleep you know well that's was my
hope but I couldn't sleep and my cousins
woke up and he said let's go hunting
again I said you know what I'm gonna
finish this book and I ended up burying
the whole thing that night and I went
home I told my wife I said you know look
we don't have a terrible life but we're
wearing ourselves out every month we're
wondering where our money went we have
no money left and I said would you like
to give this a shot and she said sure so
Whitney Nick goes deer hunting and he
comes home crazy what did you say I say
well let's go to the class and see what
it's about and so we took the FPU class
and we went every week couldn't wait to
get to the next week and it was just
kind of as soon as we got pumped it was
there was no stopping us yeah from there
so once she locked arms and both of you
could see the vision it was time to go
we got our neighbors on board they send
up for a class a couple he teaches what
they signed up so we just tell everybody
about it well thank you thank you very
much I'm proud for you guys
congratulations
that is a long road what was the hardest
part of this for you guys saying no to a
lot of things like no to going on
vacation with friends cuz we were a
young married couple and people wanting
to go out of town and we're like now we
can't go we can't afford it because we
really couldn't no you need to pay off
things first yeah yeah I enjoyed your
podcast third day on the word no we
don't use it enough anymore in our
society and and that was what we had to
do we just said no not in a rude way but
no we've got a future ahead so it was
tough not doing a lot of things but now
we can we can do a lot of things it
sounds like you guys worked together
unified very very well but what was the
biggest budget fight
in the four years so in the grocery
envelope oh yeah you would think because
I'm I'm the heavier of the two that I
would want more groceries but no I I was
happy with baloney and crackers every
month but she wouldn't spend a lot of
money and get all the fancy foods and
that was our biggest argument but other
than that we really stuck to it
very good so yeah Whitney Sharon was the
same way she she tells people all the
time now they ask her what it was like
to be broke and she said I just had one
goal I just wanted to go to the grocery
store one time and buy anything I wanted
to buy him mm-hmm
one time I want to be able to fill up my
buggy or two buggies or three buggies
and I'll think about it just one time
and now that she can she doesn't but I
can't wait till next month is looking
our fridge and see what we have yeah oh
yeah no payments now baby yeah so how's
it feel now that you don't have any
payments after all this time it's still
surreal hadn't really quite set in to be
honest with you and we're gonna try to
celebrate a little bit while we're down
here and have some fun but it's a bright
future and brought your little son with
you right Levi how old is Levi he'll be
three in April all right and we have a
we have a bun in the oven too all right
only excellent fun well you guys have a
great time at the hockey game tonight
I'm so proud of you this is very very
good
Levi ran straight past them for those of
you looking at your radio you missed
that that's hilarious the cookies are in
there that's great he knows right where
to go who did see Miss Dorothy you care
anything about his dad mom that's
perfect I love it
all right here we go Nick and Whitney
and
and Levi's 118 thousand dollars paid off
in four years and eleven months making
sixty two now ninety two a year count it
down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one way to go you two your rock stars
that was awesome absolutely awesome very
well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim